What are kids these days smokin?
Well it ain’t your momma’s weed.
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews
Not that I would know from experience, but
it there’s a rumor that weed strains these
days, are a little different from what your
parents might have smoked back in the day.
And the blame is placed on THC.
Tetrahydrocannabinol acts a lot like the cannabinoids
your body naturally produces.
The cannabinoid receptors in your brain do
a lot of different things, they have a hand
in pain reduction, pleasure, memory, sensations,
and other stuff.
But THC is also the thing that gives marijuana,
well... its high and euphoric feeling.
Basically the more THC, the stronger the high.
Potency has been monitored for about forty
years.
But the rumor is lately that today’s pot
boasts more THC than in prior years.
While some data might be skewed because of
out of date testing procedures or sample size
variations, there does seems to be a general
trend upward.
As some pot users demand stronger, longer
highs, producers are happy to accommodate.
One study presented at the 249th National
Meeting & Exposition of the American Chemical
Society found that THC levels of 30% are pretty
common in parts of Colorado where marijuana
has been legal since 2012.
But like 30 years ago THC levels were usually
under 10% according to one of the authors
of the study.
And some researchers, like Michael Kahn, the
president of Massachusetts Cannabis Research,
think that "the mega-potent strains may soon
represent the norm”.
So, yeah pot is a little stronger today than
it was when your mom was a teen.
While high THC might seem like a great idea
for those looking to get high, some strains
of pot are bred to be the opposite.
Low THC but high in other compounds like Cannabidiol
(CBD), one of dozens of other active compounds
found in marijuana.
Strains like this are newer and aren’t great
sellers, except in a few cases.
Like one strain called Charlotte’s Web,
named after a little girl who uses its extract
to cure her seizures.
Today, there’s a market developing for strains
low in THC but high in CBD, for medical purposes
for other diseases like schizophrenia and
alzheimer's.
But THC has medicinal benefits too, like it’s
been shown to reduce tumor growth in patients.
But it’s difficult to deal with its potential
healing properties while also dealing with
the high.
So researchers are currently working on separating
the high inducing properties from the medicinal
benefits.
In one study published in the journal PLOS
Biology, researchers found that the psychoactive
component of THC runs through different neural
pathways than its other components.
THC works on a lot of different receptors,
like cannabinoid receptors and serotonin receptors.
The researchers found that by removing one
of the serotonin receptors in mice, (5HT2AR),
they were able to reduce some of the negative
side effects of the compound like memory disfunction.
But it didn’t change some of the good effects
like pain relief.
While the researchers caution against people
self medicating, they hope that their research
might lead to synthetic weed.
All of the medicine but none of the high.
On the topic of controlled substances there’s
also been some research into the medical properties
of LSD.
In case you missed it, here’s a video I
did.
And we’ll put the link in the description
below, if you’re on moble.
So what do you think of medical marijuana?
Debate in the comments below